speaking of inappropriate like the most
inappropriate thing happened to me at a
uk convention surprisingly oh okay i
think i've told this story like a
million times but [ __ ] it we'll say it
here again it's the one where like
uh i mean i should tell the story as it
happened in order
okay naturally so i'm just finished with
a panel right you know killed it
answered all these questions
like a boss yeah i haven't heard that
phrase in a while wow
yeah right so and then when you're done
with the panel you'll be like all right
i'll take pictures outside you know
the line yeah so i'm taking pictures and
the first one comes up first girl
she's like 14 13. and i'm taking a
picture
she and she's like smiling like hey uh
by the way can i grab your ass
and i'm like oh this one yeah and i'm
like i'm like
what what do you mean do you know what
you just said little girl
and she was like uh and i was like um no
i think no no why would you ask that
yeah
okay whatever so and then you know next
picture fine next picture fine and as
i'm taking this next picture
i feel this like grip like tightening on
my ass
that like and it's getting space this
grip
this grip gets like [ __ ] iron clad
i'm like turning around i'm like hey
what the [ __ ]
and i was in awe because i turn around
and she's just like
and i'm like what are you doing in my
head i'm like uh
cause i'm like how the [ __ ] do i react
to this yeah i don't like swatter away
like a fly yeah
so she grabbed it and then when i turned
around she [ __ ] ran off yeah
what the [ __ ] and i'm looking at the guy
who's helping me to my hand i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] was that he's like
dude what the [ __ ] and he went to go
like go after her and like to like tell
her off but
she won how many years ago was this it's
like three or four
mcm no this is like this really small
london
one a tiny one because like i got a
similar thing happened to me
uh at uh like some of the one of the
early mcm's right
right and i was so i was i was having a
meet-up and uh
it was like it was like one of one of my
very first meetups and it was just
as i'd like just after i started dating
sid so it was like sydney's first
uk anime convention as well and so i was
having this meetup and we were taking
pictures and everything
and then this girl comes to take a
picture
and you can immediately you can
immediately tell that she was not
respecting like personal boundaries she
was
very very touchy-feely worst yeah and
sydney's like razor eyes lasered in on
it immediately right
immediately i i could feel like the
death clear
on this girl without having to look at
sydney right in the middle of the
[ __ ] like harry potter voldemort like
one battle
so so i know that sydney's watching
everything and she's like being really
touchy-feely and i'm just
i'm just like i'm trying to just be like
okay you know i have my personal
boundaries i'll take a picture and
everything
and so we're going for the picture and
she like goes on for like a full-on hug
like it's it's like i'm just there being
like the hey
and she she just grabs me like that yeah
it hugs me
and then i i i didn't even i didn't need
to see
what sydney's face was but i could feel
it i could feel it
and then afterwards i'm like oh yeah
thank you for coming to my meetup
and she and uh she goes in for a [ __ ]
kiss
and i had to like turn my cheek i like i
turn my cheek in time but she
she goes for my mouth and then i turn it
she hits she hits my cheek and then i
just hear
sydney like i've never heard sydney make
this noise ever again but she [ __ ]
hissed
[ __ ] snakes
same same as your girl she just [ __ ]
runs off before i could say anything and
i'm just like
what what just happened what am i
supposed to do in this situation you
know what the worst part was
when i got home that day i go on [ __ ]
twitter and she replied to my tweet
being like hi
i'm the girl who grabbed your ass it
felt good
and i was like first and then you were
like first of all thank you
second of all what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
i was like you know that's i would
probably be like dude that was super
[ __ ] inappropriate like why did you
do that and she was like oh i didn't
realize i'm like
i didn't realize what the [ __ ] you
didn't realize which family
what like what kind of family were you
raised in where it's like oh yes hello
so hello what are they doing like
[ __ ] measuring your firmness every
[ __ ] day
what year what year was this oh [ __ ]
this must have been like 2000
fox 16 17. that's the thing right it's
like i feel like because i have a
similar story that happened around that
time dude what the [ __ ] yeah
and this is i had just like started
going out with aki but this is before we
went public
so this is like the convention that i
met akian and that was like
two days like literally two days after
we decided like oh yeah let's start
going out
yeah and we were doing a signing
together this [ __ ] girl comes up to
me
and she she's dressed in like i think it
was like madoka magic or something but
she had like a giant wand
right like a massive like staff and she
puts it down and she's like
hi joey and i'm like oh no it's one of
these kinds of girls all right hey
what's up
and she's like can you uh sign the stuff
i'm like yeah sure and start signing it
and this is like
also here's a question but can i be your
anime expo waifu
and i just kind of stopped and how to
how to trigger
a flight or fl fighter
and the moment she said i just kind of
stopped and just looked up i was like
could you say that again please because
in my head i'm staying panicking and
same with sydney right i could feel the
[ __ ] glare of lucky
right on my [ __ ] neck like i didn't
even have to look over i'm like i know
you're staring at me
and uh and of course right i have the
pressure from here and the pressure
right in front of me right there's two
women staring at me for totally
different reasons
yeah and i just [ __ ] panicked right i
couldn't like because
at that point i was like i couldn't say
like yeah short jokingly because my
woman is glad there's no right answer in
there
but i also couldn't say no right because
i don't want to hurt her feelings and
she lined up you know all this time to
like
meet me and so i just [ __ ] panicked
and i said
i don't know i got ranks
reply back being like then can i come to
the top of the ranking and
i said well you got to learn to give up
yeah and i was like
ah i don't know man like it takes time
i was just bullshitting the entire time
and the moment and she's like oh okay no
worries
again tried to go in for a kiss and i
just [ __ ] like dodged that [ __ ] so
she only got me on the chicken and she
walked off
and then aki under her breath was like
what do you mean by ranks
i'm just like i'm sorry what are you
supposed to say in that situation
there is no right answer but there is no
right answer that was definitely said
the most incorrect
that was definitely the wrong answer
i felt so bad after just politely
declined to be like oh thank you but no
i know but like i was at that stage
where i really couldn't say no like it
was at that point where i didn't know
any better right that was like probably
like my second
or third signing session ever yeah you
mean like
the the story i told with sydney where
where you don't know how to react in a
situation you don't know how to react
and because you don't want to like make
them upset right because they line up
all this time you're like are you
[ __ ] lined up for me like i'm not
anything special so like like that was
at the point as well where like any
absurd thing that they would request i
would just [ __ ] do it just to make
them happy
so i remember like at this like canada
convention the first dude that came up
to me
was like can you sign my ass i'm like oh
okay
and like i thought it was like just his
pants right yeah this guy fully [ __ ]
dacks like his pants off
shows in the middle of the convention
[ __ ]
first dude in the lion plants his bare
ass on the table
and was like sign here
did you [ __ ] wipe down this table
oh my goodness i mean that's sanitation
yeah i mean you know there's a bottle of
hand sanitizer
any sign anything i just [ __ ] emptied
that
sanitizer that's so disgusting i know i
think i would vomit on his ass
yeah so like i signed him making sure
not to actually touch his arse like with
my hand
and i did it i was like i need one of
those like garbage picking up things and
just
like [ __ ] it the tongs like from far
away
it's like a radioactive suit you know
that again like that was the point what
is wrong with anime fans
i was like i didn't know any and the
like same convention as the guy who
planted his ass
there was another girl who came up and
she looked really [ __ ] what
convention was this oh this uh i think
this is otakuthon
in montreal and uh and this girl that
came up looked and sounded really
[ __ ] normal right until she said
can you sign my arm and she had like
drawn out
like a box for me to sign on the arm and
i'm like oh that's
kind of weird i'm like i have a piece of
paper and she's like no no i want you to
sign my arm
so i was like all right i just and i had
a lot of people to go through it right
so i just [ __ ] saying
yeah and i'm like oh do you want like a
piece of paper for me to sign it on and
she's like oh no no it's okay i'm
getting this tattooed
and i was like no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
i did a really shitty job as well it was
like the most like [ __ ]
messed up signature i've ever did i'm
like no no no no no no no please don't
do that i'm begging you
i actually said like i'm begging you
don't [ __ ] do it it's just like
okay i'll think about it i'm like no no
no no no don't think about it
just [ __ ]